there we have the board in front of us
down to less than four minutes knight c5
on the board a big moment for aneesh
kiri really
so close to victory which would move him
just half a point behind ian nepomnerchi
and of course let's just remind our
viewers that aneesh
unfortunately has the worst tiebreak
amongst all these players
uh compared to yan and
but still a very very critical point to
be in the race
and also we can say i think that to win
in this style it it it gives you an
extra self-confidence
and it gives some hard time for the
opponents also that
wow he was really doing a great job
right
so it's when we were talking about it
that how is it when you lose the game
and it is is it a difference when you
blunder something
or your opponent outplayed you it's the
same thing with the win
i mean you can win sometimes but you can
really win
the way that you remember for rest of
your life
and this is a game which will be in the
collection of best
50 games probably if there is going to
be written something like that because
it's
it's there right you really feel the
essence of the quality
i couldn't agree more especially the
move knight e4 i mean that's one for the
history books
and i think not just this one his win
against uh uh
against van gaal as well just the way
just kind of domination that he showed
in that game
making these slow moves doing everything
right and then that was
a very positional strategic kind of a
game and then he suddenly switches to
this it was a catalan i think
and then in this one just absolutely
blowing the position open with this idea
of
knight e4 uh you're absolutely right
i think we can all expect a best game of
anishiri collection and this game would
be right up there
i and now we have a move rookie eight
but i don't know exactly what
uh dink has in mind this is 97
[Music]
97. and probably uh you know one thing
is like i've played thing
on couple of occasions and when he gets
a bad position his body language like as
you can see you know
on the screen that he is visibly upset
but we should not be fooled by it
i've learned it the hard way and he is
very tenacious you know
it's better to finish him off and not
give him any chance here
what about queen b4 here
he goes for queen to c4 so he's
immediately threatening a discovered
check and saying that now king d8 you've
got knight b7
uh also rook b8 ideas queen c4 what
happens to rook c6 now does he want to
know
i guess
but d5 doesn't seem to be a bad movie
there
also queen b4 here because suddenly d5
bishop f7
you should have seven before but queen
before after
is just mate no um
how i mean you pick up the rook on c6
after 97 queen b7
yep king d8
no i mean after queen before after king
i think ding just resigned he just
reasoning
wow what an incredible
breathtaking game by anish giri and a
very very well deserved win
and we see that the players are
analyzing i mean knight e4
uh just amazing stuff that